i was pretty lost looking for a new
anime this season mainly because of how
surprising
spring 2021 was towards the last few
weeks from the astronomical endings of
both odd taxi and
link click and so it almost felt a bit
unfair to summer 2021 to stand in the
shadows of such huge anime to walk in
those footsteps
and i had a tough time scrubbing for
something new to interest me
and then i tried out a show i'd heard
whispers about little tidbits and
mentions of here and there and i gave it
a shot
that show being of course sunnyboy
sunnyboy
sonyboy now i want to preface by making
it clear that i don't think sonyboy is
the only good show this season if that
was
what was implied by the title it's much
more simple than that
it's really just the only one i'm
currently watching
or the only original one actually
because i am watching kobayashi san 2
but
see i guess there's a lot of
discrepancies with that title but anyway
i felt like there might be a lot of this
season 2
who are confused on what to watch or
have yet to see any standouts yet
and i wanted to make this video to
convince you to watch sunnyboy or at
least to give it a try
because i think it has a lot of
potential and it has already piqued my
interest only two episodes in which is
pretty difficult to do
so yeah let's check it out i think the
reason that sunnyboy already started
receiving hype and anticipation before
the show even
aired why i heard about it in the first
place was because it's actually being
directed by shingo natsume
who you might recognize as the director
of one punch man season one which
you know probably needs no introduction
on that one and mind you i want to make
it clear that it's one punch man season
one
not season two which was given to jc's
staff instead of madhouse who directed
season one
and so sunnyboy is kind of like
compensation it seems for
everyone who felt disappointed in one
punch man season 2
and wanted to go back to the roots of
the anime with shingo natsume
and madhouse studios who directed the
original show that blew up and impressed
just about everyone across the world
plus this series is based on no source
material at all
meaning that it is written and is
essentially all up to the creative
directive
of shingo natsume even more reason to
believe that this is kind of like his
comeback after that
after such a big impact on the anime
community sunnyboy is his new project
and he's also assisted by a great staff
original character designs from hisashi
ogushi who worked on perfect blue which
is another pretty famous movie
so to make a long story short the cast
working on this show has a pretty strong
reputation that had people already
wanting to see what was in store from
the start before the show even aired
but that is probably the line i draw the
only part of sunnyboy that i can compare
to one punch man season one
and honestly i don't think you could
even find any similarities plot wise
because sunny boy is very strange
i'd say the premise of sunnyboy is
very simple very very short to describe
one day a school drifts into an
alternate dimension of nothingness
and the only people who are left are 36
boys and girls in the school
but some of them also begin to develop
superpowers
and and that's about it there's
basically no backstory on anyone to
start off with nothing to build up to
this moment you are immediately thrown
into sunnyboy now normally i get kind of
turned away from series that solely
involved teenagers amidst some mystery
or dangerous power it's a genre that is
often done really poorly myoga
danganronpa don't even get me started on
king's game
all of these kinds of supernatural
stories with dark twists involving just
a cast of students
don't have a great track record for
whatever reason
and one of the reasons from the start
that i think it stood out was
because of the characters or at least
the main cast in the first episode or
two
they feel very unique there's this
really interesting dynamic between the
student council and the normal students
the student council is basically led by
this guy named hoshi who is this very
conniving looking guy who almost seems
evil at surface level
but is contrasted by how he acts as he's
one of the three heads of the school
basically
one of the few characters who is trying
to make sure that things don't get out
of hand which
we know they will of course it's a group
of teenagers with superpowers
it almost reminds me of lord of the
flies if you're similar with that series
it was one of those for some reason
every school forced you to watch in
elementary school but basically it
follows a bunch of kids who are stranded
on an abandoned island
and very quickly they resort to savagery
and almost primal life that
goes really badly it's one of the
forbearers of the genre of
kids with no adult supervision start
going crazy to sum it up
which would have probably happened in
sunnyboy actually if it weren't for the
student council who take the
rules very seriously in this show they
are the commanding power there is a
level of superiority about them
and it's because the show has
superpowers
because the student council have the
ability to enforce their rule and make
sure that people don't step
out of line it's not an equal playing
grounds like the stories like this
mostly are this dynamic is the most
important part of episode 1 by far it
really sets a certain tone for the show
to come that even though it's a bunch of
kids
not only will it get out of hand at
times but conflict will arise
certainly that needs to be solved among
themselves and they need to have
order it's pretty mature ideas despite
the young cast and another aspect that i
think is really important to sunnyboy's
growing success
is the mystery because once again
bringing up spring 2021
and two of the most successful original
shows of the season
odd taxi and link click they're both
mysteries
2021 is very much elevating this genre
to new levels or at least
putting it back in the spotlight which i
personally love
it's amazing to be enthralled in a
really good mystery it's one of my
favorite genres
and of course sunnyboy is guaranteed to
be a mystery because the biggest issue
of the show
is finding out why the hell all of these
students are trapped in some strange
dimension
and why they suddenly have powers is
this part of earth
is there a way to escape how do they
even get here
i think sunnyboy has an endless amount
of possible ways it can go which
is kind of scary actually because the
series could end up being way different
from how we initially expect
it could be like aliens making the
dimension or some experiment gone wrong
or just some
weird supernatural world they live in
that we didn't even expect
like it could be anything at this rate
but regardless i think the idea of
giving these students powers on top of
everything
does add depth to the show and they're
all very different too it's it's not
like my hero where all of them are used
for one specific purpose for fighting
villains
one of them has like animal crossing
items that he can make from nothing and
give to other people
and one can fly and one can dish out
punishments how he sees fit to people
and force them to do his bidding almost
it's it's really dynamic it keeps you on
your toes
but all this praise isn't to say that
the show is perfect or anything like
that because i think it's far from
perfect especially with
only two or three episodes now down for
one as i mentioned earlier i can
definitely see the story really
spiraling in later episodes once we find
the reason that the kids are trapped in
some alternate dimension
like a gurren lagann type story where
they suddenly end up fighting god in
space
or attack on titan where we suddenly
realize that there's an entire world
outside of these walls
which can definitely be done right
because both of the shows that i just
mentioned
did this concept perfectly but because
there isn't an original manga that
sunnyboy is based off of it's just a
completely
original story it can definitely get out
of hand and no one is there to control
it except for
shingo natsume and even if he has a
great reputation
people make mistakes i also think the
main character nagara is
kind of lackluster he doesn't have
really anything of note to his character
except that he's kind of quiet and
mysterious and apathetic towards things
which i do think will end up being
important later on but
right now he's just kind of mindlessly
there in the story for me without doing
much for his own
it's kind of carried by the other more
dynamic and interesting characters
so i'm looking forward to see how he
grows and if he doesn't then
that'll be pretty disappointing so yeah
today was a pretty short video
in all honesty it's it's hard to say a
lot about this show because there's so
few episodes out and i do normally like
to take a more analytical route
but i felt like it was important to
bring light to sunnyboy before it
potentially gets big which
i can definitely see happening what are
you guys thoughts on it have you seen it
are you interested by what i said if not
at all what are other shows that you're
watching this season i i'd love to hear
some
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses